mary jean is or john or mary jean is the
system administrator of a big website
the website requires multiple web
servers and database servers to run each
web server costs forty dollars per month
and each database server costs 60
dollars per month
to get an idea of the monthly bill her
company will have to pay mary jean
makes a little table so this is
this is the number of potential web
servers and this is the number of
database servers so these are different
scenarios
what is the expression that describes a
monthly hosting bill for n web servers
and m database servers so let's think
about what's going on right here when
she has one web server and one database
server well she has to pay forty dollars
per month for that one web server and
sixty dollars a month for that one
database server and when you add that
together you get a hundred dollars
now here in the second scenario just two
web servers and one database server so
here she's multiplying 40 times two
because that's how many web servers she
has so she's gonna have to pay 80 a
month for the web servers and still
sixty dollars per month for the one
database server let's skip to one that's
more interesting so here she has five
web servers and two database servers so
she pays forty dollars per month for
each of the five web servers and she
pays sixty dollars a month for each of
the two database servers so if you
wanted to write an expression that
describes the monthly hosting bill for n
web servers and m database servers well
you see here you see this pattern she
pays 40 dollars per month for every web
server that she has so she has n web
server she's going to have to pay 40 per
month times per server times n servers
and then
she's paying sixty dollars a month per
database server
so if she has m database servers she's
gonna have to pay sixty dollars per
month per server times the number of
servers
so this right over here is the
expression for the monthly hosting
billing cost and you can see that right
over here if you view this as m or sorry
if you view this as n the number of web
servers and this as m
you see that when
n is 20 and m is 10
then you get 40 times 20 plus 60 times
10. 40 times n
plus 60 times
m and then you would get your actual
value